this video will explain the story of
Starfield we'll be talking about the
main story and ending as well as the
choices within them before we begin
though huge thanks to Bethesda for
giving me a code for the game early
allowing me to get some hands-on
experience of that before release also
spoiler warning ahead when we talked
about the main story and ending of
Starfield so if you don't want that
spoil for you please be sure to finish
it and come back and finally if you like
videos about the stories of games and
you're in the right place I have
strictly informative videos like this
one on a multitude of games as well as
analysis videos where I explain to you
the story of a game or series also
critiquing its quality along the way if
any of that sounds appealing to you feel
free to stick around and watch more
videos on the channel without further
Ado though let's get started
before we get to the main story we have
to take a bit of a history lesson so we
can understand how we got here there are
a lot of events that occurred throughout
starfield's history but I'll spare the
Minor Details and we focus on the major
points where things officially start to
get interesting as around 2100 where
Humanity has started Living in space a
few years after that Humanity created
grab Drive technology allowing for ships
to go across the Galaxy in seconds
unfortunately around 2150 the Earth's
magnetosphere started weakening causing
Humanity to flee to the Stars before the
Earth was destroyed by solar radiation
to accomplish this feat a new Force
called the United colonies was created
to get people off Earth and onto other
planets they were fortunately successful
and life was once again able to thrive
but not everyone was super Keen to be
under this new rule though so the United
Colonies created The Centaurus
Proclamation which allowed citizens to
go to distant planets and create their
own land this eventually led to the
creation of the freestyle Collective and
house for roon a few years later as is
human nature conflict would eventually
arise amongst the new groups and would
result in an all-out War tensions
between the three-star Collective and
the United colonies were growing day by
day until the two wage war on what is
known as The Colony War it's still even
today the most brutal war in Humanity's
history as both forces use ground troops
warships and even local wildlife and
their battles as for house Varun they
worship what they call the Great Serpent
as they believe that the arrival of the
great servant was inevitable and that
any non-believers would be killed upon
its arrival so they started a war called
The Serpent's crusade in hopes of
spreading their faith and territory in
the name of their God
eventually all this was handled in the
Galaxy was at peace once again but not
without issues tensions between the
United Colonies and the free star
Collective still exist but aren't as bad
as before and the Galaxy is still
healing from the attacks and house Varun
has turned around due to New Management
who still believe in the serpent God but
refused to kill people in order to
spread their belief although some
members of the faction still believe in
the old ways over the next hundred years
or so numerous planets will be colonized
in new groups like the UC Vanguard and
constellation would be formed which
leads us to 2330 where star fuel begins
our story starts with us as a minor for
Argos extractors we're a new recruit
here looking for work before we stumble
across a rare artifact it seems to wield
enough power to knock us out unconscious
while also showing us a vision of
somewhere in space when we awake we're
unsure what happened but are able to get
our bearings straight our supervisor
named Lynn called one of her contacts
bear in order to trade this piece of
metal in exchange for credits Barrett
also seemed to bring with him a gang of
space pirates from the Crimson Fleet
while we will come across a variety of
spacers and Pirates the Crimson Fleet is
the top pirate gang the led by a guy
named Delgado who is currently at odds
of the United Colonies in fact one of
the game's faction quest lines evolves
around these two groups as for this
small group it seems like Barrett
managed to piss a few of them off so we
have to take them out Lin isn't too
happy with having Pirates invade her
workplace so Barrett's going to stay
behind while we take his place and
deliver the artifact to his group
constellation they are for the most part
a myth as many people don't care about
their goals that much and some may not
even know of the group's existence their
whole goal is to explore the stars and
uncover what's out there but seeing as
Humanity has already done that it's no
wonder many don't take them serious
easily their leader is one Sebastian
Banks but he went off on a mission one
day and never came back leaving Sarah
Morgan as the current chair of the
organization due to their unique goal
the group is from all walks of life some
are religious While others are atheists
some are proficient in mechanics and
Science and some are just the group's
finances in a way they are the
stereotypical group of outcasts who all
have their own opinions and feelings but
unite under one common goal which for
them is uncovering the mysteries of our
universe the group is rightfully shocked
though to see someone who is not Barrett
not only enter their building but also
be accompanied by Vasco the group's
robot after we clarify the
misunderstanding we give the group The
artifact and see the hunks of metal
interact with each other Sarah then asks
if we want to join the group and
continue to hunt for the artifacts and
that we've uncovered something truly
unique which we happily accept from here
90 of the main quest is going to be
centered around Gathering these new
artifacts as well as meeting some of the
other members who weren't there upon our
arrival Sarah wants to accompany us on
our first mission to see how we do we'd
see how Troublesome this search has
become as the artifacts only react to
each other's energy without them they're
just literal hunks of men metal so many
people just Pawn them for credits or in
this case use them as a hood ornament
after this Mission we have three more
missions that revolve around meeting
members of the crew Vladimir Sam and
Barrett Barrett were already familiar
with but Sam Coe is related to Solomon
KO the man who created a keyless City on
the planet Aquila so he's quite the
popular guy within the Freestar
Collective and Vladimir mainly stays
aboard the eye which is a giant station
right above new Atlantis that helps
track locations of the artifacts and
other similar phenomena through Vladimir
we also meet another member of
constellation called andreja both these
individuals are also further
confirmation that constellations members
are from all walks of life as Vladimir
used to be a part of the Crimson Fleet
before joining the group and andreja is
first seen killing a member of House of
Arun claiming that this isn't the first
time they've tried to kill her once
that's complete we return back to
Vladimir who you guessed it has another
artifact for us to find but this one is
different as the gravitational anomaly
that these things produce is much larger
than the previous ones meaning this
could be something different while that
hypothesis was right as it's not just a
bigger artifact but a whole ass Temple
sitting right here in the middle of the
planet upon stepping into the rings that
the temple creates were given new
abilities as well as another artifact
which confirms that these artifacts and
the temples are linked naturally we
check in a constellation to show off our
new powers which worries and excites
everyone before being sent out on yet
another scavenger hunt just like before
though this Hunt is different Walter
wants us to accompany him to the city of
neon to get another artifact which
involves a bit more legwork than before
this is also where we get one of our
choices although admittedly it's not too
important when we meet with the owner of
the artifacts we have the option of
killing him or hearing him out assuming
you let him speak you can also decide
the fate of the guy who sold it to us
originally neither of these outcomes
have any effect on the story as we end
up with the artifact anyway but it's
just here to give the player more things
to choose what's really important is
what happens after as Once We Gather the
artifact and leave the city we're
contacted by a random ship called Helix
this person claims that their people
have killed others for these artifacts
that we possess and that we should give
up the hunt for these entirely they also
reveal their names to be starborn and
claim that they'll spare us if we hand
over the artifact we can actually
jettison the artifact allowing them to
take it but it doesn't seem to change
much anyway seeing as we get it back at
the end of the game if you don't then
you have to grab jump away to another
system before they kill you everyone is
then called back to the lodge to talk
about who that was just about all of
them think it's aliens someone from a
remote distant Colony finally showing
their face or some agent of the divines
but we'll see them for ourselves soon
enough from here on out though these
starborn are going to be at the sites of
every artifact we find so we'll have to
deal with them each time we want to
continue our search fortunately this
next artifact isn't at its original site
but rather on a collector ship owned by
Petrov he was apparently given to this
by someone who touched it first and has
such experience those Visions we see
throughout the game Petrov has been
trying to figure out if this guy's
claims are true but with no luck similar
to our job with Walter this Runner card
is a bit more brain rather than brawned
but assuming you retrieve the artifact
you'll be greeted by yet another
starborn just like our previous member
this one seems to shoot first and ask
questions later as they've taken control
of the eye and possibly killed our crew
this starboard known as the hunter also
plans to take the artifacts for himself
and has come into the lodge to get them
right now we're then forced to choose
the lodge or the eye if you choose the
eye those at the lodge will stay behind
to defend the artifact while you check
on the other crew then you report back
to the lodge to find out where Noel went
as she took the artifacts and ran this
leads to a chase scene where we have to
race through new Atlantis to get to our
ship while avoiding the hunter as
Bethesda further proves that they need
to make bigger hallways as I got caught
on every person on the way there
afterward you'll then go back to the eye
to make sure everyone is okay and then
explain what happened if you stay back
at the lodge then you skip that visit to
the eye in the beginning fight off the
hunters you could buy no old time and
then everyone runs away as a group the
big reveal is that in both outcomes one
of the crew will die but that decision
is entirely based on your Affinity with
them I've seen some guides report that
Barrett dies in this outcome despite
that not happening to me which is what
led me to figure out what the cause is
basically the game takes each member of
constellation in those areas determines
who has the highest Affinity with you
and then kills them off so for example
the people at the lodge were Sam Noelle
Walter and Mateo I chose the eye the
first time through and since Sam had the
highest Affinity as he's technically the
only one who can have Affinity out of
the four he was the one who died for the
other outcome the crewmates on the eye
were Vladimir Barrett Sarah and andreja
and since I was currently attempting to
romance Sarah she had the highest
Affinity meaning she was the one who
died I'm not entirely sure if there's a
way to game the system by having some of
the crew be in different places but no
matter how you go about it Whoever has
the best relationship with you in the
place you don't choose will die by the
end of the quest unfortunately for me
that person was Sam Upon returning to
the guy were then greeted by the Hunter
and his ship Scorpius whether
intentionally or not he gave us a few
clues about the artifacts as he used the
words unity and armillary the unity is
the end goal of this whole mission but
the armillary is the sphere that the
artifacts are forming back at the lodge
we'll learn this a bit later but
basically putting all the artifacts
together makes them react to each other
and after all of them are together they
create the armillary this armillary is
how we reach the unity which is why each
of the starboard wants these artifacts
why the unity is so special though is
unclear at least for now but Vladimir
gives us the option of choosing an
outpost or our ship as the location for
the armillary due to the presence of its
power other starborn are likely going to
attack the location it's placed at so I
personally kept it on the ship
at the moment though we're kind of stuck
as the team doesn't know what to do
about the starborn and is equally
confused about this Unity they speak of
Mateo though claims to have heard that
word before on some of the teachings he
received from keeper aquilis who is the
head of the religious group The sanctum
universum once we talk to the keeper he
explains that in their religion it is
known that a pilgrim found the true
meaning of Unity by visiting each of the
three religious bodies of Starfield the
sanctum universum the house of
Enlightenment and house for roon the
keeper seems to believe that the story
of the pilgrim is a code and each of the
groups he visited will have a piece of
this code so we'll have to talk to the
other groups to figure out their history
before we go though aquilis tells us
that the pilgrim commonly used a phrase
called infinitum addendum as he spent
his final days contemplating his
contribution to the infinite
the house of Enlightenment is the first
group we meet but despite me calling
them religious they really aren't they
actually Veer more towards atheism than
anything as the house doesn't focus on a
common theology or God but instead
focuses on helping people in more
practical ways like providing shelter or
food however the group does have a
historical tale about a being called The
Drifter and how this being talked to the
house about the power of two in
cooperation part of The house's core
ideals is strengthening your own core
morality but The Drifter said if it's
built upon one person's morality what
about the second person what if that
second person disagrees he was trying to
get the house to recognize that people
should understand how others lift them
up as cooperation is how we push forward
as a species in all fairness though Mr
Singh here claims that the founding
members may have made this up as atheism
was not so accepted back then so the
group was likely trying to write
scripture that didn't sound too
religious but got the message of the
group across
our final stop is house for roon but
seeing as their Embassy building is
vacant and most of them would rather
shoot us than talk our only option is a
lone prisoner here on new Atlantis given
that her entire conversation revolves
around her religion and their whole
Crusade was about spreading their faith
in that religion she's actually more
than happy to speak to us about the
Great Serpent according to her their
leader Jinan Varun met a non-believer
who gave him a false prophecy regarding
their religion Jinan didn't take too
kindly to this and killed the man right
where he stood until the non-believer
came back a few days later to talk to
him again about the prophecy this cycle
of killing the man only for him to
return happened four times over the
course of 120 rotations of the planet so
we have a pilgrim a Drifter and a
non-believer all of whom are likely the
same person and three groups who have
had various different interactions and
feelings towards this being fortunately
keeper aquilis is able to put together
the mystery using all this info as he
claims that infinitum addendum when
broken down has the words in and
dominant referred to the system of indom
the power of two refers to the second
planet in that system in the Forum 120
from house Varun are the coordinates
this takes us to the planet named indom
2 and upon reaching side coordinates we
find a vacant Outpost located within the
Outpost is a locked door that forces to
read the Pilgrim's writings in order to
open it the pilgrim has six different
writings that you can find that I'll
talk about his journey and his meaning
with various humans for my
interpretation it seems to paint the
pilgrim as a starborn as he references
the unity a few times in his writing and
how he wants to pass through it again to
begin the process Anew which if you beat
the game then you'll know exactly what
he's talking about he also uses the word
humans to address these people implying
that he is not one the pilgrim starts
off on his own but realizes that he
needs the help of others in order to
survive so he works with some other
humans but as is human nature they start
to ask questions about him and his
thoughts it frustrates him those he
wants them to understand what he knows
but they seem to misinterpret and forget
what he said what is clear that he cares
for them as he's only anointed them
because he wants them to understand for
example one of his assistants had asked
if there was anything higher or above
the unity and he almost had a fit over
the question as he can't understand how
someone could misunderstand something
like that to this degree over time
though he starts to realize that
Humanity while maddening is necessary
and that cooperation is important as
being alone has started driving him mad
he then takes some time to reflect on
his life here as well as his past and
future decisions of what they could do
for him he's at a Crossroads though as
he finds pleasure in finding the
artifacts and gaining more power like
the powers we got from the temple but he
also finds pleasure in helping these
people in this universe the only
difference being is that the pleasure of
power is short-term and Fades almost
immediately whereas helping his
assistant is a long-term pleasure and
one that stays with him long after the
deed has been done I'll Circle back to
the Pilgrim's writings later when the
plot starts to reveal itself but a
common theme of Starfield is the idea of
Technology power and greed and how it
can help corrupt those that want it as
well as Unity not just being an object
that we're seeking but an idea that
banding together as humans allows us to
accomplish anything like constellation a
group of like-minded people working
together to accomplish a seemingly
impossible goal
regardless the final writing of the
pilgrim tells us to go to the Planet
Hollywood 2 to find the scorpion sting
this adds us to a puzzle that ends with
us finding the Hunter's fortunately
he's not here to kill us but rather talk
he and the other star-born called the
Emissary which was the one we ran into
back on neon want to discuss what's
going on and finally give us some
answers upon talking with them we
discovered that these star-born are not
only human but they are also Sam and
keeper aquilis
sort of so the Emissary is whoever died
in that previous mission that we talked
about earlier as such Sam appeared for
me but it will likely be different for
you the hunter is always keeper aquilis
but neither of these beings are the same
ones we know these starborn are those
people but from a different Universe in
their Universe they found the unity and
entered it thus becoming starborn this
Unity then shot them into another
Universe similar to that of our own and
were given the choice of finding the
artifacts or not basically the setting
of Starfield has multiple alternate
universes all of which include the same
people and events the Emissary is a Sam
from Another Universe one where he
entered the unity that constellation was
trying to find and the hunters from a
universe were keeper aquilis went
through the unity to clarify while they
are human they aren't technically human
as they're starborn they look human as
that's what they were before but once
you are reborn you're considered
starborn this distinction is only odd
because Starfield doesn't have any other
alien races as opposed to something like
Mass Effect just think of the starborn
As A different race entirely even though
these beings do look human despite both
being starborn though they don't agree
on the use of of the artifacts the
Emissary believes that they should keep
the artifacts and use them as a means to
judge people in order to see if they're
worthy of entering the unity he goes on
to say that in every Universe the
star-born fight over these artifacts
causing innocent lives to be lost so he
wants to stop this Anarchy from being
Unleashed onto the world and judge who's
worthy while the hunter only looks out
for number one and once the artifacts
purely for himself it's actually rather
ironic as keeper aquilis a man of God is
the one going against the established
order that decides people's worthiness
the reason these two decided to even
talk to us though is because our
survival is new the hunter claims that
in all the universes they go to they
always have a meeting like this they
were particularly interested in this one
as we were in attendance this time each
of them has gone through hundreds if not
thousands of different universes yet in
every single one of them we have died
that's why they're handling things
differently now as it's possible that
the unity is trying to change something
as this is an outcome that hasn't
happened yet the Emissary also says that
we're the only member of constellation
to change physically we may be different
but we have the same mindset which is a
nice little nod to all of our created
characters and how even though we all
look different we're still all the
latest members to join constellation due
to this Revelation though the two of
them have declared a truce between
themselves and us as well as encouraging
us to side with one of them we don't
have to make a decision now but we can
talk to them one-on-one to get a better
understanding of their thoughts on the
artifacts once that's finished we can go
back to the lodge to inform
constellation of what just happened but
not before the Emissary gives us a key
card for a facility on Earth's moon this
will lead us to another artifact but
also a lesson what he's referring to is
what occurred on the moon and how that
change human history forever before we
do that though we have one more artifact
to find and I'd rather talk about this
first since the lesson the Emissary is
talking about leads right into the
endings this last artifact is found at
nishina station but upon entering the
atmosphere we hear a distress call from
someone who needs help however once we
arrive everything seems normal we ask
the front desk clerk about the distress
call but he claims not to know of such a
thing so we go with him to meet the
director of the facility before being
transported to a different version of
the same facility this one more rundown
than the other the nashina station is
starting to look like the ishimura if
you catch my drift fortunately no
Necromorphs exist here's there's just
these scorpion-esque creatures all over
the place in this version is a person
named Raphael who was the one who issued
the distress call after constantly
teleporting back and forth we learned
that this is the same facility with two
different versions there are quite a few
variables here but the only constant and
the cause of the problem is the particle
accelerator in the basement basically
the facility was experimenting with an
artifact by shooting the particle
accelerator at it this however caused an
accident but the results are different
in each version Raphael was the one
running the experiment but in the normal
version he was the only one who died in
the accident but in the rundown version
everyone died but him the director then
determines that we could solve the
problem by turning it off ourselves
which is something they couldn't do
before thanks to that part of the
facility being on lockdown the issue is
that while the particle accelerator will
stop the merging of the two facilities
whatever one we stop it in is the cannon
facility so to speak so we have to
choose the actual result of this though
are odd as it's unclear what will
actually happen will it disappear
forever or will it be in an alternate
universe we know alternate universes
exist thanks to the starborn so it's
entirely possible for this to be the
true outcome of nishina station in
another universe but would this kill the
crew or just change them in any way
because we still don't know if this
would make them disappear or just simply
take them to another Universe sort of
like a weird Mandela effect it's a very
interesting idea posed by the game but
either option results in us getting the
artifact with the major difference being
that Raphael can join us on the ship as
our crew member assuming you chose his
reality
with that though we can now return to
the lesson the Emissary has for us which
starts on an outpost on the Earth's moon
what this Outpost was used for was
designing and testing the first grab
jump in human history the other thing we
do all the time we want to go to a
different solar system that was first
launched here as I stated before in the
history lesson this was able to send a
ship from the moon to Jupiter in a
matter of minutes but how it was able to
work is the important part here and is
the lesson the Emissary wants us to
learn to do that we're gonna have to go
back to Earth but despite that sounding
rather exciting it's anything but the
scanners say that the air is filled with
CO2 and that the Flora and Fauna are
gone and we can see that those reports
are correct as Earth looks nothing more
than just a Rocky ball of mass the cause
of this is why we're here at NASA's
headquarters in the first place inside
are numerous old relics in the past such
as the Apollo 11 shuttle the Mars rover
and numerous other projects NASA helped
produce but once you're done basking in
the history and also trying to figure
out how a spacesuit for 1970 has better
stats and one from 2330 you can go to
the basement and find out that the grab
jump technology originated from the
artifacts before Humanity could create
grav Drive Tech they were exploring Mars
and found a rare object which we know is
the artifacts one of the head
researchers Victor Isa crunched her
numbers and Ransom tests and ended up
using this as the basis for the grav
jump nowadays Humanity has been using
grab jump technology in more efficient
ways but the original launch was done
using an artifact thanks to space
exploration and science basically being
exploded overnight everyone and their
mothers and then the space Community got
together to create more of these drives
this is what allowed Humanity to make
the Stars their home but it would
unfortunately be their new permanent
home as the grave drives destroyed the
Earth's magnetosphere for those unaware
the magnetosphere is a fancy way of
describing a planet's magnetic field the
Earth like all planets has one but every
planet's field is different due to its
size composition and a dozen other
factors this field is incredibly useful
and arguably one of the reasons we're
even still alive is it protects us from
harmful solar and Cosmic radiation this
view was broken due to the constant use
of grab jumping which is why the Earth
was eventually destroyed by solar
radiation as the magnetosphere was no
longer able to protect us so in an
effort to explore the Stars we ended up
making the Stars our permanent home by
ruining the original home we started on
that's the lesson the Emissary wanted us
to learn
he wanted us to know about our past
mistakes and how greed and power can
have disastrous outcomes especially when
you consider that Victor Isa seemed to
know this was going to happen the whole
time after the discovery that the Earth
was going to be destroyed one of the lab
members calls him out on this and asks
him if he knew this was going to happen
the thing is though is that Victor had
good reason to continue his research as
he was the one who touched the artifact
and as we know the first person that
touched sees a vision within this Vision
he met with himself and I told him
everything that had happened since how
Humanity would make the grav Drive Tech
and how they would destroy the Earth but
in doing so this would allow them to
create a whole new Earth on a distant
planet a shining Beacon of human culture
art music and lifestyle and we know
that's true as new Atlantis is exactly
what he's talking about Humanity may
have lost our old home in doing so but
we were able to create new homes for
everyone on a variety of planets and our
galaxy all of this is meant to ask you
how you feel about this was the world of
Starfield worth sacrificing the Earth
for or should we have stayed and found
another way it's a similar question that
Victor had to answer and he felt that it
was a worthy sacrifice the Emissary
believes this to foolish as while the
artifacts gave Humanity the knowledge of
space it didn't give them the wisdom to
see what was lying just ahead of them
that's why the Emissary wants to be the
judge of the artifacts as the people of
Earth were given a choice as he asks
what Gave Victor the right to decide the
fate of mankind he wants to keep the
artifacts for himself as he doesn't want
them to fall into the wrong hands the
hunter however opposes the Emissary and
says that without Earth's death the
settled systems wouldn't exist and
that's also not considering the fact
that the Earth may have likely died out
anyway due to war disease and famine
their viewpoints are not just the
artifacts but also the fate of the Earth
are important as you're going to have to
decide who to side with the Emissary or
the hunter but this Choice isn't a
binary one as you could reject both and
carve your own path either outcome
results in one or both of them waiting
on what they call the berry Temple this
Temple is where the actual last artifact
is located as the two star borns agreed
years ago that whoever didn't get chosen
by us would wait at the temple for us to
arrive similar to that meeting we had
with them this final fight always occurs
in every other universe so they decided
to talk about the process a while ago to
make sure things are more streamlined
and fair that's why they are allowing us
time to prepare ahead of time as they
too are gathering their forces
regardless of whether or not one of the
starborn accompanies you you have to get
through waves of different starborn all
of whom have their own sets of magical
powers that they've acquired from other
universes temples along the way you'll
also run into these Visions from the
past both of them claim that the temple
is always testing you which could point
to why we're seeing these but it's also
possible that these are universes that
we're peering into one of which has a
universe in which we're killed once we
make it to the end of the temple we find
one or both of the starborn waiting for
us from here we're forced to fight them
but if you're crafty enough you can talk
them down if you want to the fight will
have us teleport to various different
places that we visited throughout our
Journeys like the Astro Lounge on neon
and even the NASA headquarters but with
the hunters emissaries ours and the
temples artifacts in hand we have every
single piece of the armillary and can
now use it to get to the unity upon
using the grav drive with the armalary
and our ship we're sent to the unity and
here to greet us is
us according to us we're as much of a
part of everything as everything else
this is because all things are made from
energy and since energy never disappears
it's just thrown out into the
ever-expanding world of space but
everything that dies and lives goes
through the unity in a way you could
argue that this being is the unity
although like a lot of things he says
they're not exactly accurate when we ask
where we are he says the word the center
of everything but also claims that the
word Center is not correct but the best
possible word to use for us to
understand you've heard a conversation
with someone where you had to dumb down
your words when speaking to them and
explain it in a way that they would
understand that's what they're doing the
unity isn't really the center of
everything but he's only saying that
because the mere existence of this thing
is too incomprehensible for us to
understand so he's just dumbing it down
for us just for the sake of
understanding what's going on here we're
gonna go with what he tells us this
means that the unity is the creator of
everything in terms of scale we first
have planets these planets form together
to make a solar system but multiple
solar systems belong under one Galaxy
like the Milky Way but we know that
there's is also other galaxies out there
like the Andromeda galaxy for example
these galaxies all make up our universe
but thanks to Starfield we know that
there are multiple universes adding yet
another item to our scale the unity is
the center of all of that whereas the
sun is the center of the solar system
and the galactic center is the center of
the Milky Way the unity is the center of
all things as such the unity could be
attributed as the origin point of
everything from the stars to planets to
galaxies to universes everything started
here this is likely why our character
tells us that they've seen all we have
been could have been and what we will
become because it knows all the outcomes
it's seen the other universes where we
make different choices after a talk with
ourselves we're given two more choices
walk through the unity and become
starborn or leave and go back to our
universe fortunately the latter is not a
Permanent Choice as you can always come
back but the former is before we go
though we are shown a few images related
to our past choices these are akin to
Fallout style and slides as they serve
the same purpose the first is the fate
of constellation the second is the fate
of the hunter or the Emissary and the
others are related to your romance
choice if you had one and your endings
of the faction quest lines if you did
them the fate of constellation seems to
be consistent throughout all the endings
which is that members that stay behind
and didn't go through the unity publish
their findings on the artifacts and the
temples which expand its base
exploration across the Galaxy as many
people took to the Stars once again to
find out what is out there as for the
starborn if you sided with the Emissary
they decided to not be reborn again and
said dedicated their time to finding
worthy people for the unity in this
universe as such many Noble and
good-hearted starborn are born under
their guidance if you sided with the
hunter then he is reborn along with you
and his Essence is spread throughout the
Galaxy which gives people more courage
to seize power for those who have it
whether it's good or ill if you win
against both of them then the powers of
the unity and starborn are once again
left in the hands of humanity to find
neither of the starborn are alive so
neither can influence the people of the
settled systems this influence is what I
was referring to regarding the hunter
see the Hunter's whole thing about
people rising up and seizing power was
not his doing it was his Essence is
doing we're told by our character that
to be reborn we must leave a part of
ourselves behind and that this part of
us could affect the people of the
settled systems it's sort of like
leaving your mark on the world but
literally they use constellation as a
helpful example and I'll do the same say
that all the members of constellation
became starborn all their Essences would
spread across the universe and their
Essence is that of exploration and
Discovery because that's where the group
was created to put it another way if you
were a terrible person in your
playthrough and lied steeled and killed
your way to the top that essence of you
would spread throughout the Universe
when you were born and influence the
people of the settled systems that's why
the Hunter's Essence gave people the
courage to take what's theirs for good
or ill because that's what he does he
takes the artifacts for his own pleasure
he's a survival of the fittest kind of
person and that mentality will spread to
others when he's reborn that's why our
character asks us about our actions and
if we're content with them and also why
he lets us go back to our universe if we
aren't satisfied if we aren't content
with our choices or how we are being
perceived then we can always go back and
change that before being reborn it's
quite a unique concept as it takes the
idea of how we influence people through
our words and actions towards them to a
much grander scale this time
once you decide that you're done with
this world you're then reborn as a
starborn well we get a nice look at the
John Starfield narratively we are now in
an alternate universe that's different
from our own mechanically it's a
canonical New Game Plus despite that we
are not done talking about the story
since it's New Game Plus we do lose some
of our old stuff mainly our inventory
and credits but we get to keep our
powers and skills as well as receive a
new ship and outfit to go along with it
we're also given one objective which is
to go to the lodge as we arrive Sarah
asks who we are but ends up realizing
there were the miner from Argos
extractors in this universe we got lost
on the way to new Atlantis and Vasco had
to deliver the artifact for us from here
we can either skip the main quest or
continue it if I had to give a
recommendation I would say continue as
now that we are starborn we get access
to starborn dialogue which has a wealth
of depth to the playthrough as it allows
you to skip certain parts of the story
or let you confuse people with your
knowledge take the first mission with
Sarah where we had to find that Vanguard
guy who used the artifact as a hood
ornament the bartender won't tell us
where he went because the guy has a tab
that needs to be paid but since we're
starborn and we already know that we can
tell the guy hey dude you barely know
where he is too so just stop wasting my
time which skips you having to pay the
tab the biggest difference between the
two options that if you continue from
the beginning then you're basically
playing dumb as you know what the
artifacts are but aren't telling the
members of constellation if you do
confess and spill out the entire plot
then it skips the main quest instead all
you have to do is talk to Vladimir who
will just give you the location of the
artifacts allowing you to gather them
whenever you want he'll also give you
the locations of the temples allowing
you to either get the powers you missed
the first time around or get upgraded
versions of current Powers you already
own once you gather all the artifacts
again the game basically shoots you to
where you meet the starborn on NASA
except this time in space and are then
forced to determine who to side with and
then the game ends just like before
however there does seem to be more than
just this but how it happens is unclear
due to how easy it is to complete a new
game plus run I was able to run through
it a few times very quickly and on my
fourth run I was surprised to find not
the members of constellation but kids
posing as them apparently the original
members disappeared and left us with all
their findings regarding the artifacts
I've seen a few other people report
other findings though such as one where
all the members of constellation are
just clones of your created character
and one where andreja allies with house
faroon and attempts to kill you these
don't seem to affect the endings though
only the method by which require the
locations of the artifacts the specific
events also seem to be random so your
fourth run may be different than mine as
for how many of these there are though
and when they appear I honestly have no
idea outside of that that's pretty much
all the new content as the endings and
the ending slides are the same which
means we have officially come to the end
of Starfield while there are many
questions left unanswered throughout the
game within the main story the two
questions left are where is Sebastian
Banks and who created the artifacts in
the temples clearly the starborn aren't
the creators of them so that mystery
Still Remains and is probably something
we'll never know regardless there is a
possibility of DLC answering these
questions since Bethesda has never been
afraid to add post-launch content either
way thank you for watching the video
today and I hope you enjoyed let me know
what you thought about Starfield as well
as the video in the comments down below
if you have any questions about the
story that still confuse you then don't
be afraid to ask as always like the
video if you enjoy and subscribe if
you're new and thank you to my returning
viewers coming back to another video be
sure to check out my other Story related
content here on the channel and with
that take care everyone goodbye